alors fabrice di vizio vous sent
bouillir et 6 passes nous joue sans même
vous serez mon lacet je crois
effectivement si vous voulez c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites je suis là
c'est ouais je pense que c'est vrai je
suis là c'est la même situation de tous
les français je suis passé par la phase
de colère et puis maintenant je passe
par la phase de résignation on se fout
de notre gueule et je l'accepté
c'est ça ouais c'est ça arrive à un
moment donné vous savez je pense qu'il
ya aussi une dynamique de résignation
moi je m'en fous la limite au bout d'un
moment comme vous le dites moi je monte
à cheval ça rien perturbé de mon
activité je monte à cheval je fais
télétravail depuis tout le temps entre
les etats-unis la france le mans fou et
apps car il va abandonner chercher
logique dans cette histoire c'est
prendre le risque de devenir fou dingue
et g j'accepte pas ce risque parce que
concrètement c'est du cinéma
tout ça c'est la bière cinéma mais enfin
je veux dire très réfléchissants deux
minutes je veux dire les promesses votre
tenue j'entends çà et là
ouï dire les promesses votre tenue donc
si je comprends bien
si demain ce que je n'espère pas nous
avons une reprise épidémique jir majeur
ce que j'espère évidemment pas nous
allons quand même continuer à maintenir
des mesures c'est ça qu'on est en train
de me dire je croyais que ce qui faisait
la dynamique
les décisions que nous prenions c'était
précisément la courbe épidémique ça et
que donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
dire quoi qu'il en soit les engagements
seront tenus
bah je crois qu'on veut dire qu'en
réalité ça dépend de la dynamique
épidémique ou alors justement ce que
vous dites fabrice parce que certaines
sources que dit fabrice quand même c'est
que je me rappelle d'une allocution du
président oui disait il faut passer en
dessous des 5000 cas de contamination
par jour aujourd'hui
là il vous l'avais dit au 15 mai on sera
à 15000 donc je comprends qu'il est
français qui se disent je comprends pas
il ya trois mois où il ya deux mois on
nous dit il faut qu'on passe en tout
sinon on n'arrivera pas à des confiné et
là on nous dit
on nous dit que 15000 tout le monde est
dehors et on est autre chose
ils sont tous venus et juste
effectivement tout le monde met pas
dehors au 15 mai fait un certain nombre
de mesures sont toujours en place et
notamment le couvre-feu qui est le plus
important accord à mettre de contenir au
caire progression des choses même
excusez moi je dis excusez moi ça je
peux pas le laisser dire docteur je veux
dire pardonnez moi on a déjà discuté ici
plein de fois mais vous pouvez pas
aujourd'hui aux français
dire que le couvre-feu pire alors qu'on
sort d'un mois de confinement que le
couvre-feu est celui qui va changer la
donne
enfin restons sérieux s'il vous plaît
j'ai repassé du couvre-feu à 19h à 21h
pas changé la donne avez-vous le moins
avez vous la moindre étude sur la
question des études un peu sérieuses sur
la question
je veux bien en débattre je suis un
homme du débat j'oublie en disant
vraiment résigné vous non mais si vous
voulez un moment donné on prend les
français pour des cons je dire ça suffit
quoi je veux dire c'est comme le coût du
masque en extérieur on attend quoi ça a
été le premier à l'enlever yann galut
maire de bourges et c'est vrai que vous
avez fait un gros coup là dessus parce
que ya plein de gens qui vous suivent
on entend de plus en plus de gens qui
disent que le marché extérieur vous êtes
d'accord avec ça on n'a pas besoin de le
mettre aujourd'hui enfin voilà on
continue à le mettre est ce qu'on
continue à prendre des amendes
d'ailleurs si on le met pas dans une
zone où on doit le mettre en 35 ans
d'accord alors vous non mais il faut
regarder comment ça s'est passé il ya du
la france à des territoires complètement
différent vous l'avez dit vous-même
il se trouve qu'à bourges l'évolution de
l'épidémie était en baisse constante on
est deux fois on a deux fois moins de
cas qu'à paris ou en région parisienne
et si vous voulez avec le préfet du cher
on a eu un échange et donc il a été
décidé qu'on l'enlevait le masque à
bourges alors qu'il existait depuis
depuis plusieurs mois et donc c'est ça
il faut s'adapter au territoire mais
pour revenir au débat calendrier au
calendrier aujourd'hui
moi ce que je constate et je ne suis pas
un soutien spécial de monsieur macron
c'est que avec ces voix là où je suis je
suis au ps je suis de gauche a comme et
là dessus je vais vous dire quelque
chose c'est que il redonne un espoir il
redonne une perspective il donne un
calendrier qui paraît au premier abord
crédible par les tarifs progressifs
moi j'en peux plus jour tous les jours
tous les jours je suis dans les rues de
bourges je discute avec ma population
avec mes habitants ils ont peuvent
plus morales sont à bout il soit vous
voulez vous dire aux gens que l'histoire
elle date quand même depuis de lui pis
moi ça va en bronze et aux nouveaux cdd
stoppant deux mamans sur une fois on met
le couvre-feu ou une fois en mai
confinement il faut on dit ça donc c'est
sarah et c est moi et avec en plus d
incompréhension totale
moi je suis intervenu pour redemander en
janvier que le lieu culturel ouvre
pourquoi j'ai fait ça cyril parce que
j'ai la chance d'avoir une une petite
fille de 9 ans qui s'appelle l'ena elle
avait besoin de basket au mois de
janvier
d'accord je vais à décathlon dans une
grande surface c'était plein à craquer
il y avait du monde et je ne peux pas
l'amener au musée je ne peux pas
l'amener au théâtre alors que lui c'est
parce que culturelles étaient étaient
fermées donc ciblé au bout d'un moment
aussi les français ne comprennent pas
certaines décisions de classe qui est
très important c'est quoi c'est de dire
voilà on a ce calendrier on va y aller
progressivement
on s'y tient moi je suis très attentif à
ce que vous avez dit cher docteur c'est
on a un taux de reproduction qui est
passé en dessous
et moi je vois aussi à l'hôpital de
bourges en réanimation il ya moins de
lits occupés en lits d'hospitalisation
classique il ya moins de lits donc j'ai
l'espoir que la partie de ces gens qui
se disent ça fait des mois et des mois
qu'on subit ça on l'accepté les
berruyers l'on accepté les habitants de
bourges comme d'ailleurs l'accepter mais
aujourd'hui je les sens très tendue mais
le rapport à cette situation